former hillstar whitney port is  definitely bikini ready for her upcoming  wedding the 30 year old fashion designer  showed off her jaw-dropping bikini  bought at her glamorous bachelorette  party in Mexico over the weekend when he  brought along a seven of her closest  friends to Cabo sadly no sign of her  former co-star Lauren Conrad the gaggle  gals stayed at the luxurious Cape hotel  enjoyed some fun in the Sun and indulged  in some fancy grub this is actually  Whitney's second bachelorette party in  August she reunited with another farmer  Hills co-star Brody Jenner during her  celebration in Vegas Whitney has been  engaged to her fiancé Tim Rosenman since  November 2013 the couple actually met on  the set of MTV's the city where Tim was  an associate producer